the left has anti-science views on
vaccines the the anti-vaccine movement
started on the left with Robert F
Kennedy jr. Bill Maher even President
Obama said that vaccines might cause
autism I'm Katherine manga award for
reason TV and I'm here today with Alex
Wurz I'll co-author of science left
behind thanks for talking with Ovalle
thanks for having me who is leaving
science behind and what well really both
sides of political spectrum Republicans
and Democrats have left science behind
we look at conservative ideology and and
their opposition to global warming into
climate change into evolution and we see
that they have left science behind but
our books focus is on the left now the
reason we focus on the left is because
you can buy several books already in the
market which slam conservatives freaking
anti science if you turn on MSNBC they
have a segment called the Republican war
on science so they said hey the
Democrats they're not always good at
science either and so we thought we need
to write a book that tells the rest the
story do you think that it's worse now
it says science become more politicized
is is there sort of a greater bending of
scientific truths for political utility
yes and it is on everything from
vaccines to nuclear power to genetic
modification to science education reform
it is literally touching all the major
hot-button science issues that have
seemed to become very politically
hot-button issues so is it even coherent
to say that conservatives are
progressives are anti science I mean
well what do people mean when they say
that that term came around during the
Bush administration and they started
saying that George Bush was anti science
and then kind of stuck and it was stuck
and applied to the entire Republican
Party and to actually to be on that to
conservatives in general and while they
do hold anti science beliefs in regard
to climate change and evolution it is
also equally true that the left has anti
science views on vaccines the the
anti-vaccine movement started on the
left with Robert F Kennedy jr. Bill
Maher even President Obama said that
vaccines might cause autism the
anti-nuclear movement is almost
exclusively on the far left
anti-fracking anti natural gas that's on
the far left so these views are on the
left and they are just as anti science
as the people they claim on the right
who are anti science what do you think
is one of the most sort of egregious
instances out there right now of people
on the Left calling people on the right
anti science when they mean something
else I think that when you call someone
anti science for having maybe
reservations about some types of
embryonic stem cell research and which
I'm in favor of embryonic stem cell
research but there are things such as
should we be creating embryos not for
Reproductive purposes but specifically
for research or should we be injecting
human embryonic stem cells into
non-human primates into see what happens
I think if you start to have ethical
challenges with some of those ideas I
don't think that's fair to say someone's
anti science because we can you get a
PhD in bioethics now i mean by allah
'this exists for a reason and so I think
having ethical issues with science
doesn't necessarily make one anti
science when you talk about the kind of
results of this anti science rhetoric of
the rise of this your anti science no
your anti science rhetoric what are some
of the policy implications you know
what's the problem with this other than
that it's sort of rhetorically ugly when
you accuse everyone of being anti
science it has a you know a dampering
effect on good public policy discourse
because when you want to have good
public policy good science policy it
involves more than just science
sometimes for instance scientists would
say we should dump as much money as
possible into fusion research because
fusion really could be the power source
of the future however when you are
sixteen trillion dollars in debt maybe
spending a trillion dollars on a fusion
research is not a good idea and I
wouldn't say that that makes them an
anti science I would say that makes
someone reasonable you know we don't
have an unlimited supply of money so
when you call everyone you disagree with
anti science that has a damping effect
because there are other considerations
in policy legal aspects economic ass
financial aspects I think that when you
have authors who write books about
Republican wars on science that's not
particularly healthy for dialogue now I
know what people are going to say well
hey did you just write a book about this
and yes and no like we wanted to address
the anti science beliefs of the
political left but we don't think it's a
democratic problem we don't say this is
the Democratic Party's fault or this is
the Republican Party's fault we say this
is a the progressive way of thinking the
progressive way of thinking doesn't Inca
encapsulate the entire Democratic Party
it's just one wing of the Democratic
Party and they embrace certain myths
like the idea that natural food is
better or natural things are better and
unnatural things are bad for you I know
Ron Bailey can go on about this that at
length and so we try to we try to take
the politics that the partisanship out
of it yes it's a political book but we
try to take the partisanship out of it
and kind of say a pox on both their
houses let's just look at the science
and take the politics out of it thank
you very much dr. bozo co-author of
science left behind and editor of real
clear science for Reason TV I'm
Catherine McCord